check out this insane situation that has
developed we
have at the same time on the one hand
trumpists
protesting where they chant fox news
sucks
and at the same time if you turn on fox
news
at least at night you have fox news
continued a platform
continuing to platform the absolute
dumbest arguments about donald trump's
so-called stolen election trump is going
crazy now
attacking fox news telling people not to
watch
because on some fox news shows they have
acknowledged you know joe biden did win
after all so trump's furious about that
some of his followers are furious about
that
but at the same time if you watch you
know
hannity janine pirro laura ingram
they're still doing all the same
sycophantic trump one and joe biden
stole it stuff and i want to look at a
few examples with you
here is one of donald trump's lawyers
arguing that corrupt voting machine
software
that some states used has been used by
the cia for its own benefit i mean this
is like conspiracy
it reads like a conspiracy fake news
article from
from a fake news website a conspiracy
website or even just like a satire
website
but this is one of donald trump's
lawyers actually saying this stuff on tv
expert reports and some documentation of
how corrupt this software is
and nobody in our government has paid
any attention to it
which makes me wonder how much the cia
has used it for its own benefit
in different places and why gina haspel
is still there in the cia is beyond my
comprehension
she should be fired immediately this
same trump lawyer that's sidney powell
she said that donald trump actually won
this election by millions of votes
how wait hold on it looks like he lost
it no no no
she says trump won by millions of votes
take a look at this
because we're fixing to overturn the
results of the election
in multiple states and president trump
won by not just hundreds of thousands of
votes but by millions of votes
that were shifted by this software that
was designed expressly for that
purpose imagine how insane it is
that this stuff is still happening on
fox news
and yet trump is still furious with them
and his supporters were chanting
fox news sucks in washington dc over the
weekend
then there's rudy giuliani rudy's
evidence that the election was rigged
against trump
it's a hunch he has he would be
surprised if philadelphia didn't cheat
but i mean the reality is the reality is
the the reality is
that i would be surprised if
philadelphia didn't cheat in this
election
they've done it in the last for the last
60 years now listen guys if he'd be
surprised that's that i mean that's as
good as definite fraud right
and then saturday night on the judge
janine pirro show
the same trump lawyer sydney powell says
they should just invalidate the election
just just delete it as if it never
happened
and never being certified no state that
had
anything done to the machine prior to
the sort of
prior to right prior to the election
without a new certification
is going to have to invalidate its votes
it's going to have to go to the state
legislatures to be decided
janine and then she goes on to say that
there were millions of votes
flipped or erased not just in swing
states
but even in states that weren't close i
am working
on the massive aspect of system-wide
election fraud definitely impacting the
swing states and likely going far beyond
that
we're talking about the alteration and
changes in millions of
votes some being dumped that were for
president trump some being flipped that
were for president trump
computers being overwritten to ignore
signatures
all kinds of different means of
manipulating the dominion
and smartmatic software that of course
we would not expect dominion or
smartmatic to admit
and then here is jesse waters airing his
suspicion
his feeling that joe biden didn't really
win
that biden was installed
he has a gut feeling guys i thought
these were the people who said facts
don't care about your feelings but jesse
waters has a feeling
that joe biden didn't really win
turbulence
obviously but it's there's a there's a
sneaking suspicion
me and a lot of americans that joe biden
was installed
somehow somewhere i can't prove this
allegation but
it's a gut feeling but that's why you do
these kind of investigations
do you kind of have that feeling too
yeah i do because it's multifaceted
and the voice at the end there was
victor davis hansen from the hoover
institution
agreeing with jesse's gut feeling just
a completely delusional segment and then
here's one last one this is really funny
texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
who offered a million dollars for proof
of voter fraud
the million dollars still hasn't been
collected shockingly
dan patrick went on fox news and said
listen this is a really clear path for
trump
if we recount georgia and arizona and
those states flip to trump
then all we need is the supreme court to
hand pennsylvania to trump and we win
don't you guys see how simple it is
recount two states and flip them
and then have the court give a third
state to trump and boom he'll be
re-elected on january 20th
the official count in georgia arizona
wisconsin pennsylvania
and remember shannon there's less than
30 000 votes
in georgia and arizona
dividing biden and trump and if those
two states
turn if they do then the supreme court
could make the decision on pennsylvania
and then trump is president so i don't
know how it's going to turn out
but we deserve a real count
to know what the real vote was so we
could have confidence in our elections
and biden should be the first person
shannon to go out there and say
look recall but the democrats brought
this on themselves shannon with their
suspicious act
so there are some real questions about
the future of fox news because
it's it's bipolar what's going on here
on the one hand they're still doing all
of this insane stuff and claiming that
trump really won
but at the same time because a couple of
reporters have said listen it's kind of
over
like trump lost that's it trump is mad
at them and trump's followers are mad at
fox news
but he still has friends in the
nighttime shows like hannity and janine
pirro
who the hell knows what to expect and
somebody
who also seems to have become completely
disconnected from reality in the last
two weeks as trump's press secretary
i want to talk about that next if you
are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link
right underneath this video